thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a groovy
wild ride with Stevo we've got Paulie
Shore this week and he's as groovy as
they come very likable guy very funny
guy and I really think that this episode
is the perfect mix of silly and and zany
and funny and serious and revealing and
uh really compelling and entertaining
it's a good one it's uh it's a lot of
fun and I've been on the Comedy Club
Circuit for many years now and I've
heard quite a few stories about how much
the ladies love Pauly Shore true story
and I'll tell you something about my
lady she loves it when I take Bluetooth
tablets why because they give me a huge
raging boner and when when I've got that
huge raging boner about 30 minutes after
I've consumed my Bluetooth tablets it's
war with her vagina I said it okay I
take Lux to pound town with that boner
and why do I have such a huge boner
because Bluetooth tablets have the same
active ingredient as both Viagra and
Cialis except they only cost a fraction
of the price and this plus they're
delicious too they make my tongue blue I
show it to luck she screams and and it's
on the Bluetooth people are very
generous to the listeners of the Wild
Ride podcast too because if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo then they're willing to give you
an entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free all you got
to do is pay five bucks for shipping and
when you're at bluetooth.com you consult
with their online medical provider and
take care of the prescription with no uh
awkward visit to the doctor's office
because it's super fast it's super easy
and like I said you get an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets in
the mail for free all you got to do is
pay five bucks for shipping you're gonna
love having the boner that they give you
so jump on this deal and let's get into
it see the way my team is
are you impressed Polly
I'm just I'm just nervous I'm just
nervous the the van's going to take off
I'm gonna wind up in [ __ ] Barstow or
some [ __ ] and my cars
[ __ ] funny dude what no kidnappings
bro yeah not not here dude this is it
this is like uh uh I do a thing with Jam
in the van yeah do you know Jam in the
van I don't know here we go no no no
it's the yes no Jam in the van they have
a van and then bands play in there and
they jam and it's dope cool it's dope
yeah so it's uh just it's just uh music
all right okay here we go we're gonna
start it like this
ladies and gentlemen Paulie Shore yeah
dude
good to see you brother this is like
this is like we we almost X out we
almost X Out each other there's a lot of
dude here yeah there's a lot of deer
yeah
a lot of dared with some pretty heavy
Burrows sprinkled on top [ __ ] it's like
Tommy Lee and Sebastian Bach ooh you
know what I mean that's very insulting
to Tommy Lee
I say that because I'm biased I'm a
major crew head I love Tommy Lee
I've been very I'm going to be
protective of Tommy Lee until the end
that's good I just took mushrooms so I'm
gonna do my whole thing like this is
that cool cool with me because I moved
to Vegas and now I can be who I'm self
which is a juggie yeah you know what I
mean it's susceptible out here nice La I
can't be a druggie people are like all
like yo you can't you can smoke weed but
out here I could do acid you know I can
drop mushrooms it's Tuesday afternoon at
two o'clock and after this I'm going to
Fremont Street bro I'm Gonna Pop Lock I
have a I have a circle down there I have
a little black [ __ ] with no arms and
no legs so he's down there so I collect
quarters and stuff you know so damn I
love it did you micro dose I'm just
kidding you're notoriously like a sober
guy right not not like a guy who is an
alcoholic who just never got loaded no I
just I'm just fortunate I don't have the
um
the thing in your veins where like you
have to have like you know like I'm good
with just two glasses of wine you know
what I mean I'm good you know I'm good
with uh you know you know joint you know
just a little bit yeah just a little bit
I I just never um had that that like you
said that ISM yeah like my dad had it my
dad was sober 40 50 years Mike binder
has it a lot of people have it where
they can't
you know so I was just lucky I didn't
have that so but I'm not definitely not
sober okay good yeah I'm not I'm not
sober you know my manager said that he
really wants me to ask you what um do
you own The Comedy Store now like what's
the story with The Comedy Store who owns
it
um my mom okay
all right my mom owns it yeah right well
we we know that your mom Mitzi yes and
uh
I'm bad at this I'm sorry for her
passing yeah yeah yeah yeah no my
brother's run it okay yeah I'm not
really I'm I'm never been really
involved as far as management there okay
you know I've always been
supportive of young comedians sure you
know whether
um you know that's that's been like
that's my biggest hard on is helping
young Comics you know what I mean so I
don't need to name all the comics that
have been opening from last 20 30 years
but that's my come from with the store
you know what I mean it's helping you
know develop comedians cool and and
that's what is um I never wanted to run
The Comedy Store you know I'm an actor
I'm a comedian and I don't want to deal
with you know insurance and alcohol
ordering and all that stuff so my
brothers are doing a great job okay so
they're yeah they're it's in the family
business and
um so that's kind of what's Happening
yeah I
I've always understood that you were uh
really really
great at running your own business of
doing stand-up as in Booking your own
gigs you've acted as your own agent your
own manager like is that is that right
like yes that's yeah I do I'm kind of
like a um a case by case so I have
different agents throw me gigs and then
I do it a lot a lot of it myself but I
think over the years I've developed
relationships with every club right and
every promoter and out there so we're
like like we're Bros right so like with
Stroop out in Ohio hefron uh we talked
we talked to endorsement and Joel yeah
Joel over it so I just go straight just
go straight to them and sometimes they
like it better that way than than
working with agents because sometimes
stuff gets thrown in between the cracks
with the agents and then like yeah well
10 Falls between the cracks right there
absolutely
so I was I'm always a big believer with
like you know with these big agencies
like yo at the end of the day if you're
bringing me money over here which is the
acting and the the commercials and the
voiceovers and and all that then you can
have my PAs right you can have my PA
personal appearances and if you can't if
you can't give me that I'm not giving
you this because it's not about the
money it's a it's it's about where the
money's coming from right does that make
sense so why give someone all this work
when they're not doing what you really
want them to do which is movies and TV
and all that others right
um so I just you know I carved it out
myself and and um
and you just kind of what you do is you
you just kind of say yo I want the same
deal as we did three years ago and
they're like great and it's done and I
work with um you know the guys over a
hyenas Randy in in in in Texas which is
a great room if you played Fort Worth
um I
I did and like I I wasn't in a comedy
club actually in in Dallas the last time
I was in Dallas I sold more tickets than
I ever ever sold in a single night well
that's because you're Stevo bro yeah it
was it was crazy I had it was like a
little over a thousand seats and I did
two shows sold out in one night that's
great yeah I was really happy with that
um but but as far as booking my own
stuff you know if I was playing you know
big venues like really big venues
outside of comedy clubs then I would get
an agent wow that's interesting because
yeah Dean Cook got to a point where he
was like himself renting out an Arenas
and putting the show together as himself
which was uh
I got gotta talk to Dan Cook about that
yeah I mean you know I mean you get to
that level and it's like wow yeah yeah
it almost seems like at that level like
who cares about ten percent
exactly exactly
um but yeah you know so so dude we
we worked together and uh in uh a movie
I guess we weren't in the same scenes
but I don't know I wanted to I wanted to
do some acting with you though right you
know with it and and it was a movie that
came out during the pandemic it was
called guest house yeah Sam macaroni
directed by our buddy Sam macaroni hey
Sam what's going on come on guys yeah he
did a great job she really did he did a
great job he folk it was very focused
and it was like and it was uh I forget
what the what the situation was when it
was initially started this movie like um
if it was like on an independent level
it was really with a pretty low budget I
think and
um got the day that I was working on
this set I feel like the um like the
higher-ups from uh Lionsgate came to the
set and uh were like maybe impressed
enough that they that they didn't
bought it I think I don't know I think
it's called a negative pickup right
that's yeah that's right yeah so it's
basically when it when it's financed
independently by whoever and then from
there the you know that's what I do
that's what happened with biodome wow
the movie I did biodome it was it was uh
uh it was uh um produced independently
like guest house yeah and then MGM
picked it up but yeah that's what
happened and so Guest House gets gets
picked up however it got picked up and
uh it seemed a little bit
counter-intuitive that you know like
this is kind of sort of a random cast
and it was this huge hit like there were
these articles coming out that uh that
it was um one of the most watched movies
in uh the entire year of 2020 during the
pandemic
and does it come out straight onto
Netflix yeah
I think so I mean I know yeah I know
that it just kind of uh my friend Jared
Getz uh who's uh he's uh he worked he
worked for Lionsgate for a long time he
was uh the one that kind of you know got
it out there he's the one he's like a
sales guy right and he sold it to or
license it to Netflix and I think it's
actually coming back on Netflix this
this December which is like you know in
a couple months yeah but yeah it's you
know
the business is that our business is
that you don't [ __ ] know you just you
you put your heart into every project
you you know it starts with the script
right you know and you know I really
worked really hard with Sam on the
script you know as far as softening my
character so it wasn't you know my guy
wasn't a piece of [ __ ] you know what I
mean and likable and lovable oh my God
that penis bomb that penis bombing yeah
the funniest [ __ ] thing I've ever
seen in a movie yeah except for uh The
Silence of the Lamb's bit and then this
last jackass one I think I laughed so
hard at that penis bong yeah it was it
it was it was yeah that was Sam Sam's
idea they wrote that um yeah but yeah it
just you know it's just everything lined
up it did you know everything lined up
Sam was so great to work with and um he
trusted me I trusted him right he
brought in cast members I brought in
cast members a lot of people you know a
lot of people uh did favor for that
movie yeah yeah and you know you got
Bobby Lee in it and you got Eric Griffin
and Punky Punky uh Punky Johnson from uh
SNL now she's on SNL you're in it uh uh
uh Billy Zanes in it and it's just a
really fun and it's the first R-rated
comedy I've ever done all my movies have
not been R-rated so so for me it was
like you know doing coke on camera I'm
like I got really like my my my anxiety
went up because I'm like dude and I
thought a Scarface and I'm like well
that's not real coke right I'm playing
this role I don't believe that you've
never done Coke that's true yeah yeah
yeah exactly and uh um so so uh but no
but but but you you know just kind of
going there as an actor and going there
as the character you know was a little
bit uh risque for me because that was
more my stand-up but but this but it
worked out great we softened the
character and and you know it worked
really really well and I was really
really happy with it you know I bet yeah
and just how well it did yeah there's
timing that's what I was saying like in
the business you it's not just about the
movie but it's about the timing right so
you know the pandemic actually helped us
yeah big time the uh I mean you've been
just relentlessly performing stand up
without ever stopping for how many years
now over 30 35 years yeah yeah and it's
because I love it for sure yeah I love
it and because you know in my personal
life I I mean everyone in my life has
been uh it's almost like um what's the
word uh decimated
decimated you know it is reduced by 10
percent
okay so uh what does it mean when
they're gone ah deceased
okay deceased everyone you're saying the
right word decimate like you know this
guy gets decimated online but
you pointed out what happened like a
Desi the root word of Desi means by ten
so like technically everybody that's
using it is using it wrong it's it's
it's a word that people use for they
were devastated no no people were like
oh dude like he gets owned like
decimated like well yeah so what happens
if your family gets hit by a bus and
everyone gets taken out or cause they
are now deceased no but like destroyed
or [ __ ] okay so so to answer your
question
um everyone in my life has been gone you
know I I don't realize yeah everyone I'm
by myself you know my my parents my
sister died everyone yeah and so I feel
I feel that I'm by myself in this world
and I'm not married and I don't have
kids I have a beautiful dog it's been
amazing that you've managed to not have
kids
yes
and I have a beautiful dog and I have
beautiful friends so this back to the
original question that you asked me I
get a lot of authentic authentic love
from my fans and I really truly love
when they come up to me you know all
through Vegas wherever I'm at oh my God
you know I mean you get it too right I
mean some people Bobby Lee [ __ ] hates
it you know like I was with him and Nick
Schwartz and [ __ ] we did a show in
Edmonton he's like because Bobby Lee's
really famous now and he and it's it's
not easy for him and for me I open my
heart yeah you know what I mean and I
feel what they feel because because what
I've done for some people has really
affected them and so I get that personal
I get that feeling of love and and
that's part of the reason why I continue
to do my stand besides you know when I'm
on stage it's a it's a stress reliever
wow you know it's a stressor lever I'm
more comfortable on stage than I am like
you know just in in you know in that so
there's a reason why I've been touring
for 30 35 years I love it and I've
actually you know Mike binder just
opened for me he's you know Mike binder
so my binder directed The Comedy sir
documentary yeah the five-part
documentary and he's a great comic he
started at the store at 19 years old he
did stand up from 19 to 30 and then he
stopped and he just started directing a
lot of [ __ ] movies wow and he did he
directed Bill Burr's last two uh Netflix
specials paper tiger and then Live at
Red Rocks yeah so he directed those and
um and he's opening he opened for me
open opening for me now and he was just
like you know he wrote he's got a um a
great website called comedy world where
he talks about you know everyone and you
know talk about Dane Cook and blah blah
blah but he just did a really nice piece
about you know how it just how I have
just been out there and I become my
father
I've literally become my father my my
stand-up is I feel like when I'm on
stage like my on my dad because my dad
was a great comic like a really good
comic like a lot of people don't know no
do you know anything about my father I
don't yes so my dad opened for Elvis for
10 years wow cured with Elvis in that
movie yes he is his name's on the
billboard okay so if you see the Elvis
sign says Sammy Shore underneath it yeah
so my dad's the real he's the one who
started it and so he you know toured
with Sinatra and Sammy Davis and and
Tony Bennett and Tony Orlando and Bob
Hope and and he's got a book out called
the warm-up which is you know warming up
for all these you know Barbra Streisand
he did The Ed Sullivan Show so a lot of
people don't know that my father yeah at
that time was it usual to have a
comedian open for a musical act it
wasn't it wasn't but what happened was
is my dad was opening for Tom Jones here
in Las Vegas and Elvis Presley was in
the audience is so Elvis saw my dad open
for Tom Jones and after the show came
backstage and said Sammy you're really
funny we want to go on tour so then my
dad went on tour with Elvis He had
played The Forum and and went all over
wow so I'm kind of because I'm 54 now
and my dad my dad um he he uh you know
that's when he was you know popping you
know and so I feel like I'm my father
right now on stage which is you know
which is cool that's great you know what
I mean so um yeah my dad was very
special yeah he died at 92. wow so he
lived he lived he lived a long life but
yeah I miss
and I miss my family I miss my mom and
dad like tremendously because I was
really close with both of my parents you
know sometimes when people
people's parents die
um they're like oh my parents died oh it
sucks like my parents that death has
really affected me and it still affected
me you know it's hard
yeah um yeah
1992. yeah I was about 18 so you would
have been in the morning or like 20 or
early 20s yeah so yeah so your dad got
to see you on MTV yeah my dad got to see
all the movies and and he got to see all
that stuff and uh it was weird for him
it was really weird for him because you
know here he was you know he became
mitzi's Shore's ex-husband because my
mom was super famous from the store and
then all of a sudden that was hard for
him you know what I mean because he was
trying to make it you know what I mean
because everyone knows Mitzi Shore in
the comments they don't know the the
father and then all of a sudden his son
makes it and then he's like known as
Paulie Shore's father but it was hard
for him and really jealous and you know
there was that thing but then he became
really proud and he kind of got over it
and then he opened for me for 25 years
so yeah he opened on tour for me for 25
years it was my mom's idea my mom and
which was weird because my Mom hated my
dad because he was a cheater and he was
this and an alcoholic and all that [ __ ]
but towards the end of their lives you
know he she was like you know what I
think it'd be good for him to open for
you and I was like really you [ __ ]
hate the guy and so he opened for me
yeah it was beautiful I haven't chopped
on him doing the math and it doesn't
seem to add up that there were 25 years
for him to open for you well I'll do a
little bit of math right now it has been
way too many days since I shaved and I
used to spend way too much money on my
razors but ever since I started using
Harry's shaving products it's no problem
I don't even care if I've got a bunch of
dense stubble grown in because my five
blade razor from Harry's will just rip
right through it and if you go to
harrys.com Stevo check out what they're
gonna give you this starter kit it's got
the weighted ergonomic handle the five
blade razor the travel case to protect
the blades the foaming shave gel and the
body wash this is a 16 value but for the
listeners with the Wild Ride podcast
it's only three bucks telling you I love
this company their stuff is so
affordable it's so high quality there's
no gimmicks it's just classy it's what
you need and it's all I use
I'm not kidding at all I love this
product
I'm telling you you cannot get a
smoother better shave than you can with
Harry's shaving products so one more
time go to
harrys.com
Stevo for this starter kit 16 value all
you pay is three bucks jump on this deal
it's epic and let's get back to it it
started it started uh well he died in
2019.
he died in 2019 so he was opening for me
up until he was 87. so yeah open up for
eight so he was 87 the last gig I did
with him was was in Portland Oregon when
he was like 87 so he started opening for
me like in the late 90s
you know just going out so that's late
90s to you know to 2000 yeah 15. it's
weird because
um typically especially if you're in a
comedy club the the feature you know you
might have a an emcee dude like five or
ten minutes if feature you might do 15
or 20 minutes and then the headliner
will do like 45 minutes to an hour
feature Comics get like maybe
150 bucks a show but then if the feature
comic is your dad yeah I paid him more
yeah I'd hate him more yeah of course
how much time do you give them I gave
him you know 20 25. cool but it was cool
because you know it it worked because
like he would come out and give me [ __ ]
and start [ __ ] with me and saying
that you know he he stole it from me and
then I would come out after him I would
say now you guys know I'm so [ __ ] up
you know what I mean because it made
sense because a lot of people know you
know the people that are there they know
the movies or the TV [ __ ] and they don't
know like the history so they have your
actual dad and and it was kind of cool
because like I'm going like yo this is
really my dad this isn't like some
[ __ ] old guy that I just like right
and pretending that's my dad yeah so
yeah it was cool you know and Jeff Ross
was always like you know you don't know
how lucky you are you know to have your
father you know he always said that to
me like you know I wish I had my father
you know with me you know so
you know it's you know it's a it's a day
by day thing for for me you know it's
kind of like uh emotionally with you
know my fam my family yeah and you said
that your mom was super famous with The
Comedy Store yeah
um
and now
like the comedy store has become like
more iconic than ever I think uh the Joe
Rogan's Love Of The Comedy Store had a
lot to do with that like he's got such a
platform and he would just say so much
about the comedy store then the the
five-part documentary that you were
talking about Plus on Showtime They had
a like a a fictional scripted story
which was totally based on The Comedy
Store it's like
Olive and and your mom got to see that
like um right I just get to see to see
these things well she started it with my
father yeah oh oh oh oh oh I oh I'm oh
she got to see this stuff
um
not really no not not really no she she
kind of checked out when she started
getting sick okay you know what I mean
and when she was sick the club wasn't
really doing that well it was kind of
you know it's just one of those it's
it's it's everybody's home right I don't
know what else to say it's you know it's
everybody's home so it's kind of like
home base and in in the history there
and then you know you got all the the
the the the people that you know have
the history there but you know yes it's
it's doing well now but unfortunately
unfortunately there isn't a Mitzi Shore
there right you know what I mean someone
that I mean there's great talent Bookers
there and they're all doing a fantastic
job but it's just not my mom
you know what I mean because my mom had
that touch
where she would really you know develop
you and I do that with a lot of the
comics you know I love helping Comics
you know I'll give them pointers and
bring them on the road and say this and
that and a lot of the guys that
um have opened for me because they've
opened for me and I've given those years
and years of stage time they're so much
better like Jesus Trejo yeah I love him
yeah he he was terrible when he first
started with me you know he was doing
only 10 minutes and you know and then he
worked for me with me for eight years he
opened for and he's just like obese now
and you can just go down the list Bobby
Lee and everyone and who you say Ari
Manis did you ever work with ours yeah
Ari yeah or of course Ari's open for me
uh Ari shaffir opened for me Steve
renazizio open for me Ari uh uh you know
oh Bobby Lee opened for me for 10 years
Wow when he wasn't you know what I mean
so so you it's I think it's important
rhythmic rhythmically for a comedian to
work the road and the store equally okay
because the styles are completely
different the store is a different room
it's a style yeah it's the Cadence right
like it's hard to get a laugh at the
store like you gotta yeah even like you
know at skank Fest you know um you know
I went on stage I'm sure you did the
shows you know it's they're not there to
see us right they're there just to see
the show so as a stand-up you kind of
you know you go oh it's different
yeah yeah because when you're on stage
here you can be you here at the Virgin
but there it's like it's just like the
stores skank Fest they're not there to
see us they're there to see it so
rhythmically you have to shift on stage
for that particular audience and you
have to kind of maneuver and if you're
good enough you know I was talking to
Eric Griffin about this as well is
you'll figure it out you know right
um but uh uh yeah it's it's really
interesting you make that point
um because doing stand up like clearly
when I'm on tour it's my show people are
there to see me and
I would be so intimidated because
I came in to stand up from another area
and that's always like it's a blessing
that I come into stand up and I already
have a built-in audience but it's a
curse that I'm not known for stand up
and there's like some pushback and it
seems like it's like people don't
connect me to stand up so I would be so
intimidated to go do local spots in La I
would be like you know especially to
work out new material it's like wait a
second like new material that's not like
like really ready and like I'm so
insecure like in L.A it's not my show
people aren't there to see me there's
important like uh people in the audience
like industry people like other
comedians it's so much more pressure and
uh and and that that went away you know
that went away now when I'm putting
together a new show like chunk by chunk
I work out the chunks in like 10 minute
sets at the store at the Laugh Factory
at The Improv well you know that's
that's what's happened you know I was on
uh what's his name Wolf the guy with the
tattoos all over his face
um yeah uh Jason Ellis yes what isn't
his nickname wolf yeah Hawking the wolf
yeah yeah yeah so I was talking about
you actually right on his podcast
yesterday I was also talking about Tom
Green
because you three guys are very similar
right so for the audience listening is
that these guys Tom Green you and wolf I
come wolf yeah uh started late in the
game you know and and you know I said
hey you know what if you love it then
you'll be all right it doesn't matter
where you start you know what I mean
because at the end of the day the
stand-up is something that's inside of
you you're like you know what I mean if
you love it you're not doing it just for
the money you're not doing it you know
just for the check and you're doing it
because you yo I gotta talk about my
chick I gotta talk about this stuff so
for you guys like Tom Green same thing
you know he started off he didn't start
off as a stand-up so he actually did Tom
Green uh did start off as a stand-up
when he was uh like 15 or something yeah
he made it as a sketch I mean he made it
he made it as the man on the street yeah
yeah and uh and God is like Tom Green
his um his so I I've encouraged him over
the years I'm like Tom people love like
all the stuff you did on the Tom Green
Show on MTV all that all those like
crazy gags like the man on the street
stuff that you did and he uh he just
wants to leave that in his past I'm like
like I'm like man embrace it mix it all
together like give you know and and he
really wants to to not do that stuff
that he broke out with on MTV and he
wants to do pure like pure stand up and
and uh he he loves it so much too Tom
Green like cares so much about doing
stand-up comedy uh I and I'm impressed
by his approach to it and for me I'm
just such a rabbit attention to [ __ ]
I've got to be the center of attention
like I've just got to and like it's just
so built into me that I've got to be up
there doing it well I know your name's
on the on your bus in front with his
face his face
you guys were in a bus and and
everything is Stevo so when you're
driving down the street right people are
[ __ ] stupid right I think that's
crazy how does that work with your
relationship you're married or I'm
engaged yeah we're gonna wear a ring out
of respect for for my fiance cool and
then how does it work work with because
I I've had a very difficult time and
that kind of uh um uh romantic yeah that
thing because you know I was talking to
Wolf as well is like he's got his wife
because all of us are very similar I
don't want to use the word narcissistic
because that's not a right word but
we're like you know all about everyone
we're in the business of us correct so
so how does that work with your girl
going do enough of your [ __ ] Stevo
[ __ ] right like yo babe we gotta we
gotta go have some sushi let's just go
chill and you're like but because uh
because we're looking at our lives like
yo [ __ ] we only got so much time to
live and we only need so much time to
[ __ ] create [ __ ] right and every time
I present with you that I'm taking out
time because uh the biggest currency in
life is time sure that's it you know
what I mean the money and this is that
because we're all going under the dirt
anyways at some point right so she takes
you away because that's part of the
reason why it's really hard for me to be
with one you know because they want to
be with you like so what do you do she
my girl
um works in the entertainment industry
is a set designer a stylist you know uh
like wardrobe specialist and she's kind
of been in the mix she like she's very
candid about uh you know it's it's it's
kind of tough like I've always you know
like I'm a hot chick you know like she
said she had a really tasteful and and
uh you know appropriate way to say that
she's been used to getting attention all
of her life and that it's very jarring
it's now being in in a relationship
where all the attention comes to me and
uh welcome to being a dude she had a
really
um she had a really uh healthy and
appropriate way of expressing that and
she she's very good at kind of just like
uh okay you know she humors me a lot she
puts up with me a lot and um she helps
me accomplish a lot so so when you're
saying that the relationships have
distracted you from from what you want
to accomplish I've actually got a
partner who's contributing to to my uh
my goals being achieved so do you do you
when you're about to do bits you know
the thing on the Tesla or this so you
run it by her or yeah she didn't love
the Tesla thing yeah she didn't love the
Tesla thing because she knew that in a
matter of 24 hours that I was going to
be assembling a frame to hold a car
and she's like no like yeah but that's
you're Stevo I mean what is she what did
she what did she sign up for did she not
see all the other [ __ ] it's like you're
gonna stop she she just doesn't want me
dead she doesn't want me to die yeah
well I mean [ __ ] I mean you're in the
business of you could right that's true
you know what I mean she got through it
she got through it yeah you would never
see a Jewish stunt man like him that
dude something like I'm scared just to
walk on this bus you know what I mean
yeah he's like he's like in less than 24
hours I'm gonna you mean less in less
than six hours you know we pulled that
together pretty [ __ ] quick oh yeah
what like the welding began like on the
day you know well at three o'clock in
the afternoon we get a text from Steve
saying can you reach out to construction
companies to get to get a crane built
and we're like they all close at five
and then there's like the red tape with
insurance and so it was like no let's
get a crane so we can do it ourselves
and then all of a sudden Steve was at a
Tesla Place found the guy do it and that
like by three hours later they were all
everybody's on their way down to San
Diego to Vegas and everybody's building
that so it's like yeah it's really
pretty cool man that uh like the more
crazy stuff I do the more crazy stuff
I'm able to do yeah so talk to him about
your voice okay so your voice yeah well
no I yeah but um because you remember
Wolfman Jack
um back in the 70s he was the DJ the DJ
remember Wolfman like this guy okay hey
this is Wolfman Jack on WKRP that
remember you sound like Wolfman Jack all
right so it's cool so so because your
voice was you used to smoke cigarettes
or it's not that
it's not that
um and I've gone back and forth about
being like insecure about it
um and and proud of like it being very
distinctive and and and and trademark
um in in moments when I was feeling
insecure about it like feeling that it
deteriorates and it's getting worse
um I found a voice doctor to go and and
look and maybe I thought maybe I have
like nodules on my vocal cords like
maybe this and that like maybe is it
from a stunt that you did back in the
day maybe I've done damage to it like I
would you know huffing nitrous oxide I
thought it might be part of it
um the uh voice doctor put a camera up
and and he said that I'm using to speak
I'm using like the muscles above my
vocal cords which is making this uh you
know weird thing and I was like Wow dog
like you're telling me after everything
I've been through I just suck at talking
you know I'm actually going to submit
that it is a matter of opinion whether I
suck at talking or not some people
really love my voice okay and no matter
what happens I'm definitely pretty good
at sleeping these days I mean
get a load of the recovery 78 I happen
to know for a fact that last night
17.3 percent of my time of sleep was
spent in REM sleep that is an optimal
amount for healthy adults boom how do I
know that because I wear a whoop band
okay what is a whoop band it is the
single most sophisticated Fitness
tracking device known to man period
nothing can beat it ever all of the
greatest coolest people use it right
Rogan Bert Kreischer Patty the Baddie
how many people have we talked to you on
this podcast that are raving about their
root band and they should be raving
because it gives you more insight into
your health the calories that you're
burning the exercise that you're doing
the sleep that you're getting and it's
not just sleep it's the recovery Matt
it's actually telling you how oxygenated
your blood is these days you're near the
temperature of your skin I mean they're
just taking it to new levels and by
using it motivates you to get better
sleep to take care of yourself better to
be more active and I'll tell you they're
gonna hook you up if you go to whoop.com
that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use the promo code
Stevo you're gonna get 15 off at
checkout when you sign up for your new
membership for the brand new whoop band
4.0 which is completely waterproof now
you can put the charger on there
be charging it and go completely
underwater and everything's fine this
technology is insane and again all my
favorite people are using it and so am I
so you'd be crazy not to give it a try
by going to whoop.com and using the
promo code Stevo for 15 off at checkout
take care of yourself take care of your
health and now let's get back to it and
that's really it's that simple did you
get a second opinion
um I got a vocal coach who uh served as
a second opinion and tried to teach me
and he said the same thing yeah I think
so so because I've known you for a long
time I may not know known you but I've
known of you for a long time and I would
see you on different things but you
never used to talk like that okay did
you I mean in the last five years
looking back at all maybe 20 years ago
I'm talking about I mean you've been
around for a while so yeah I think I get
old footage I think you always sound I
mean I can't tell yes you've always done
you've always had that iconic voice I
mean I remember
you know running into you 20 years ago
how long have you guys known each other
for nine years we've been working
together for nine years awesome yeah but
but you would you would watch him just
like I would watch him but he and his
voice wasn't like it was a little it was
but but it's not a cigarette thing no
it's not a cigarette thing oh wow
because Vegas they they call it Vegas
throat I don't know if you ever heard of
that it's where you live in Vegas too
long you start talking like this what's
going on because they're yeah it's the
air conditioning [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah so um I mean hey you know what I've
worked with the vocal coach who was who
was making some progress and teaching me
to speak like you know like a little bit
more
who is happening and uh I just don't
[ __ ] I didn't and as long as it
doesn't hurt I mean it'll hurt you drink
hot tea and some honey and stuff
no you know what might be good my girl
loves it she says don't [ __ ] change
it she just when I was when I was
working with the vocal coach my girl she
wasn't happy she said [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] you can also gargle with warm
salt water right okay that's pretty good
you can also gargle these nuts
yeah just kidding yeah dude
um now I saw you perform at the comedy
store
12 years ago
I think it was 2010 and it in your set I
still have the same set same jokes and
in the set you were talking about
um your uh your huge movies and the one
that you did with Brendan Frazier
and you were it was very
self-deprecating what you were doing you
were talking about how you uh when you
made this movie whether there be an
Encino Man with with uh Brendan Fraser
you made that movie you guys were that
you were the star of the movie
and that after that you were describing
how Brendan Frazier's career just from
that point like went crazy you know and
you were kind of putting yourself down
as uh you know like he was the one who
really like like went skyrocketing and
and uh I remember thinking to myself why
is Paulie up there like
bashing himself like this describing
himself as the guy whose career went
downhill Brendan Frazier's went so up
and now 12 years later it would seem
that uh that that those courses had
reversed you know you've got the guest
house the one of the most watched movies
of of 2020
there's like a a Resurgence in Pauly
Shore the stand-up is still going and
yeah I don't know um I like
self-deprecating humor yeah so um I like
making fun of myself I like playing the
victim you know I think Pauly Shore's
dad was a great example of that you know
um
I don't know I I'm very I'm very aware
of my surroundings you know I'm very
aware of you know the fact that I'm not
starring in movies you know you know I I
did star in a movie but I'm not starring
you know what I mean I mean I'm working
all the time but it wasn't like it was
you know what I mean and I'm aware of
that so I like to make fun of it in a
way I mean do you or yeah like I mean
when you started on MTV you were 19 I
was probably about uh my first time ever
yeah it's not early 20s yeah yeah so
what so what what year would it have
been when you were first on MTV uh early
90s yeah so my run on there was uh like
90 to 97 around there wow yeah and and
that was just well it was it was insane
I mean it was you know it was I I say
that I have uh uh it's like Willy Wonka
you know what I mean like I got the
golden ticket I was in my 20s I was
starring in movies I was on MTV HBO
MTV led to the movies yes yeah yeah it
was it was it was big
you know it was big
um and um
you know it was so big that it had to
stop you know in a way but I was also
and I've said this to people you know
sometimes I make decisions emotionally
and not with my head you know so what
happened was and I talk about this in my
one-man show I have a one-man show
that's doing really well right now in
Vegas all over okay yeah we just got
into the New York comedy film festival
that's going to be being another month
or so but um
you know when things like when my sitcom
didn't get picked up and and and and you
know and I was trying I was uh
transitioning from a boy to a man you
know or at the time I was 30 I was just
like I just wanted to get rid of
everyone in my life meaning managers and
agents and all that stuff and kind of
just go away and then when I try to get
representation you know a year or two
later everyone was like this they
weren't into it so then that's when I
went to therapy and then I was able to
laugh at kind of what I went through and
that's when I did Pauly Shore's dad
which to me is the best thing I've ever
done if you haven't seen Pauly Shore Is
Dead it's [ __ ] like it's very dark
and it's very funny but it appeals to
people that don't like me and it appeals
to people that like me but everyone's in
it and it's um how do we see that it's
just everywhere it's on um I don't know
it's uh I guess it's just on if you go
on Amazon or YouTube or whatever it's at
but everyone's in it from Dr Dre to Sean
and uh with the Goldberg I mean there's
like Eminem everyone is there wow but
it's Britney Spears it's just like it's
it's basically the premises I fake my
deaths become famous again and and then
I wind up becoming Fame that people find
out that I'm not dead and then they want
me dead and then I wind up in jail with
like Tommy Lee so Tommy Lee's in jail
with me so it's a movie yeah it's a
mockumentary wow Carrot Top moves into
my house but it's all played very real
and it's not played goofy when did this
come out it came out in 2003
damn yeah and it's [ __ ] it's called
Vince Vaughn's in it and Tommy Lee
Britney's been Britney Spears in 2003.
yeah Britney Spears is in it because
Larry Rudolph got was hooked what was
the production company for that I
produced it I directed I wrote it I paid
for it I did it all myself well I'm
sorry in a 20th Century Fox picked it up
wow but it's it's to me it's the best
it's dark and [ __ ] I'm in I'm in
solitary confinement in the in [ __ ]
Adam Sandler's voice comes in he's like
weasel
and I start crying and I got [ __ ] the
ghost of Sam canison appears it's
[ __ ] gnarly dude like it's a gnarly
gnarly film and then I'm always like uh
trying to figure out something epic to
watch while I'm on this video yeah watch
this if Ben Stiller's in it but it's all
played real so when you watch it you're
like [ __ ] did he die
like yeah man that's so and I did it so
incredible to me yeah
um and presumably you just had like um
you know all these people were fans of
you or you had relationships with them
they were uh just did it as favors yeah
they kind of it's like once they got
Sean Penn in it I was able to like you
know it's not like dominoes it was
dominoes after that like I got real
Tenon I've known him for for years Sean
Penn I've known for um since we first
started back in the day he said
something to me one night that really
that really kind of landed with me so we
were at the um um we're at the Chateau
Marmont and we were I have some a great
Sean Penn stories
we're going up to a suite and we're
walking with a couple girls or whatever
and Sean Penn turns around he looks at
me and he goes I don't know what it is
about you because but you you make me
laugh
and I'm like huh he goes your shit's
Universal dude you're [ __ ] just so
you know I think you're hilarious yeah I
was like you know what I mean and this
is Sean Penn and then we continue
walking so I remembered that so I called
him on it so when I pitched him the idea
I said yo I'm doing polisher is dead I
told him the premise and he's like I'll
do it no problem so I flew with my
friend Kirk Fox you know Kirk the
comedian sure yeah so he's in the scene
with Sean Penn and we flew up to San
Francisco and we just shot it and then I
[ __ ] got that tape and it was just
like if as an independent filmmaker
you're like [ __ ] I got Sean Penn and
then I actually did a documentary called
once they got Sean Penn about the making
of Pauly Shore's Dad wow which is you
know and then mini me's in it [ __ ]
Burns in it yeah like he plays my
neighbor I almost run him over it's like
it's like non-stop Kato Kaelyn's in it
he's got a comb over and [ __ ] and you
know because he was famous for his hair
sure but yeah Pauly Shore Is Dead is
like that was that to me he was the um
the the the polishers there was the
beginning part of the second part of my
career okay so because once stuff slowed
down then I started producing my own
stuff and and I've done so many things
by myself with all of those people in it
yeah like uh
like what was the budget that you made
it for I think it's like 800 000. oh wow
okay so that's not yes but yeah I spent
some money you know and then uh you know
like did you like
triple it no we kind of broke even maybe
a little bit more okay but it was but it
was it was you know it was cool you know
it was cool I didn't I mean I didn't
want to lose money did you uh sell it to
break even but
um keep profit participation for points
like once it came out no I just licensed
it I own it so I license it to 20th and
then I license it to show time and then
I license it so I own it but at some
point I definitely want Netflix to pick
it up because I think if people see this
[ __ ] they'll be like [ __ ] you know
what I mean but the one-man show right
now is getting a lot of Buzz so I have a
one-man show it's called stick with the
dancing and it's stories of my childhood
because that's what my mom said to me
when she when my mom first okay when my
mom first when I first showcased from my
Showcase from my mom Mitzi Shore the
owner of the store
um I did I did the jokes that the other
comedians wrote for me you know when I
first start I was 19 years old and I
ended with pop locking I'm a pretty good
pop locker and then after I said to my
mom I said how did I do it she said
stick with the dancing
you know what I mean right okay so so
that's the name of the the one-man show
so
um it's uh it's it's cool it's it's
stories in my childhood and it's it's
all all the stuff about you know growing
up in Beverly Hills or at the store or
the MTV days or um right you know uh you
know uh my sister dating filthy McNasty
there's all this like personal [ __ ]
um back in the day there was uh you know
the Viper Room sure yeah well years
before that in the 70s was a place
called filthy mcnasties so the owner was
a guy named filthy McNasty so he um
dated my sister so he would pick her up
on dates in a hearse with flames on the
side wow so I talk about so many inside
things so everyone is freaking out over
this so I got Radical Media is producing
it and berylstein's my managers they're
behind it and um Sandler's company you
know saw it some developing a show based
off of my childhood yeah
so is this what you're taking over The
Residency of Carrot Top with
yeah Carrot Top was telling us that uh
he had friends saying dude Paulie did
like 30 minutes of his show talking
about you and how he's gonna take over
your your show and uh
and uh and he was bashing you and and uh
and
and uh
karat top seemed to be under the
impression that a lot of people didn't
understand you were joking I'm a good
actor
he's one of my best friends yeah I mean
I love I love Scott he's yeah David I
know I love Scott yeah he's awesome no
it's you know it's very my style of
Comedy a lot of it is very Curb Your
Enthusiasm okay you know it's scripted
but it's all played in a very real way
so people don't know so I did a bit with
him
um where I say get the [ __ ] out of Vegas
you're tired dude people want to see
your [ __ ] anymore and it's on the
internet
um so that was kind of like the
beginning part but it's just like a
friendly riff right but he's uh I'm on
text message with him and Nick Cage all
the time wow yeah so Nick Nick lives
here oh [ __ ] how come nobody told us
that yeah yeah he's not gonna he doesn't
do podcasts I'm sure that he would yeah
he's like really weird on that [ __ ] yeah
I don't doubt that like um but uh man
was I a fan of his movie Wild at Heart
yeah he's great I saw that movie in the
theater like three times yeah he's right
when it came out in in 1990
what do you guys talk about on the tech
thread
just joke
you know joke he doesn't he's very
private you know so I want to respect
you know what I mean he's like doesn't
want to take pictures we take pictures
and videos all the time together but he
doesn't like to you know announce that
he's not on any social media I bet yeah
and he just likes to do he just does
movie to movie I mean you guys like four
movies he just started a movie today in
Toronto
um so he just bangs him out
that's his thing but no Scott's Scott's
a dear friend of mine and I always [ __ ]
on him and he shits on me and it's right
yeah yeah to be fair I couldn't tell if
he was joking when he was relating uh
this this developing story to us oh
really yeah he had an appointment to be
at like at one o'clock and uh and and I
said oh yeah we're doing Paulie short
necks and she's like [ __ ] dude hopefully
they don't catch each other because they
won't leave though they'll be with each
other for like a half hour shooting the
[ __ ]
so yeah no he he said he he actually
sent me a picture of you guys about two
hours ago yeah yeah he's yeah no he's uh
he's a dear friend of mine you know
God man that's great so so you moved to
Vegas like two years ago did you have
any previous
like ties to Vegas like uh outside of
just the usual being a comedian well one
of my best friends Bobby Ludington lives
here so he used to work with me he does
furniture for all the clubs okay so he's
like an upholstery guy and he's like a
family my dad's Widow Suzanne lives here
my dad passed in Vegas so you know he
lived here and then
um I have my friend Jason Strauss I
don't know if you know Jason he runs
like lava and Marquis and all those
clubs okay yeah so him him he lives here
so as far as uh uh ties just you know
I don't know I I have friends but you
know I've I've really grown to really
love this town and I've really grown to
love the locals in this town and I
helped open a new club downtown called
Wise Guys so like Wise Guys uh Keith and
and uh Salt Lake City yes do you do that
with him yeah so I helped organize that
my friend Jason owns Jason and Jonathan
they own the land and then Keith owns
the name so I hooked them up and uh key
signed I love Keys yeah I love yeah yeah
so they signed up a five-year um lease
there so it's a it's a great little Club
it's in the arts district and a lot of
people um don't know any name for a
comedy club too Wise Guys yeah like
um for all the stupid names comedy clubs
yeah
like uh comedy clubs typically prefer
like the the idea of uh being stand-up
comedy is all about uh Mastery over
language words communication you would
think that these people would come up
with better names for their clubs
yeah so um
yeah I know this is great yeah Wise Guys
is cool so that's that's here in the
arts district and um but Vegas is Vegas
is cool there's a lot of really cool
local places there's a place called
Esther's kitchen which is great food I'm
familiar with that I think yeah is that
uh vegetarian no but they have
everything they're vegan stuff and then
there's another place called uh Sparrow
and wolf that's really great and there's
a lot of great little places off the
strip a lot of great bars there's
um uh I don't know there's
you know there's a great little
Community but um how um does uh Nevada I
suppose like does do they are they like
Texans with like no state income tax is
it like uh without you part of like the
the mass Exodus out of California
because the cost of living and the taxes
just everybody just got over that it's a
certain point everybody left I know Mark
Wahlberg just moved here too he did yeah
yeah so he lives here as well so I think
people are living all over I think after
kovid the whole world kind of blew up
now like as far as like thinking about
moving somewhere like uh I would have
trouble
picking Vegas just because of the water
situation I feel like there's going to
be water wars and that Vegas like Lake
Mead is just drying up like like there's
gonna be like a Water Crisis and Vegas
seems like such a precarious place for
there not to be water I don't know I
think it's America I think yeah I think
they'll always have water it's fine you
know I I think for me it's one of those
things that um I don't like to stay
anywhere for too long right so I don't
stay here for too long I'll Bop around
you know so but the house that I have
right now sits on an acre
and it's just spread out and I have a
beautiful dog and there's a pool and
it's very cool uh he's lab Chow husky
wow his name is Buster wow yeah he's
really really a beautiful dog and um I
don't know being 54 and kind of like
wanting peace you know and living next
to Nick you know there's like you know I
have a friend now here and there's uh
someone that um you know we respect each
other and there's uh I've known him for
30 years they're just growing up his his
uh his family Dynamic is very similar to
mine
um and there's a relatability that I
have with him and um it's part of like
the whole Coppola situation yeah he
doesn't yeah he changed his name because
when he was first acting back in the
valley girls and all that stuff uh he um
he got a lot of [ __ ] from Sean Penn and
Kevin Bacon and all these guys going oh
you're just here because you're a
Coppola you know what I mean so he's
like [ __ ] that I'm gonna change my name
and it worked and now is one of the you
know top five actors in the world you
know yeah and people people love them so
you know um I don't know I think as long
as I bop around and I don't like to stay
anywhere for too long I think I'll be
all right you know yeah I've always been
that guy that just doesn't like to stay
too steady yeah you're a one-man show
does it I mean you said that you talk a
lot about your childhood but does it
sort of like bring the audience into
like where you are now and like what you
yes the last 25 years I I kind of do a
recap at the end like what I've been
doing last 25 30 years right which has
been like touring America and giving
back to my audience you know and also
doing these great independent projects
and doing these things and so it's not
like you know
um as I said this line and I think it
was a I I I I said it and I think it was
a polisher stands alone which was a
documentary I did on Showtime where I
say hey you know just because they
stopped giving me movies doesn't mean I
stopped being me right you know and it's
just like because I'm not starring in
movies because people see a movie after
movie why aren't you doing movie it's
like dude just because they took the
cameras away doesn't mean I stopped
being who I am so I continue doing what
I do I was fortunate I grew up at The
Comedy Store and I saw what not to do
and I saved my money you know so I was
very fortunate with that
um that when I made my money I saved it
so if there's any actors out there or
people in the business save your money
and don't be the bling bling guy because
you know that's gonna you know what I
mean and you know and don't marry a girl
that you think might [ __ ] you know
gouge you and [ __ ] and that's another
thing it's like not being in that
situation you know that was another
thing I was kind of you know what I mean
you get leery because when you're famous
you know it's pretty obvious why these
girls are with you right period and they
can say oh I love them I don't [ __ ] you
know what I mean stop you know what I
mean yes and no right it's very
sensitive and you know being famous and
known is a really awesome thing and
there's also some really [ __ ] up
things about it too you want to focus on
the positive stuff you make people happy
and you know you can make a nice living
and we love to do this we don't have to
[ __ ] work a normal job right you know
and we're very fortunate on that but
then you got some other [ __ ] over here
so life is yeah life is like that you
can't have everything you know what I
mean so it's it's sensitive it's very
sensitive is the one-man show up and he
said just do it well happening yeah
so we'll be at Wise Guys in a couple
weeks I've been running it there all the
time which is uh Wise Guys it's already
happened in Vegas yeah downtown downtown
we just did the space here in Vegas the
other night I'll be back there and then
I'll be at the comedy store on November
30th Comedy Store in L.A yeah in the
main room I'll be doing you should come
dude with your chick you'll [ __ ] trip
it's right after Thanksgiving it's
November 30th I think I'll be home yeah
November 30th Dr Dre's coming cool man
Jay's coming and I'm inviting some some
my celebrity friends and and yeah so
it's it's cool it's cool so I'm doing
that November 30th I'll be at Flappers
in Burbank practicing it there I like to
practice there on the 27th and then the
New York comedy film festival I'll be
premiering there on uh November 8th and
9th and it's it's a cool show and I'm
getting a lot of good responses it's
different it's a monologue bro it's a
monologue it's not like [ __ ] stand-up
at all so it's it's and it gets pretty
heavy is is there uh are there like
visual assets yes yes
it's exactly like Mike Tyson's
Undisputed Truth great so if you've seen
Maps if you've seen Mike Tyson's
Undisputed Truth he speaks and there's
videos right I travel with a Q lab
operator so if you don't know what qlab
is it's a program that basically you
know when I go he goes you know with the
with the photos and videos those cool
yeah so it's pretty dope
um and then uh yeah so it's got videos
so it's like a lot of the [ __ ] that I
talk about people don't believe it but
then when you show it you're like [ __ ]
he's not joking this is some real
precisely how I do my show oh cool okay
so you got some yeah okay so I tell
stories that are utterly implausible and
frankly unbelievable and then after each
bit I play the footage of this one I
think with you they know that it's all
true because they've seen you be [ __ ]
insane yeah well you know what I mean
you're known for like I did bump it up a
notch for this tour oh wow yeah yeah and
I have plans to continue to bump it up
another notch yeah when you did my
podcast I don't know probably a couple
years ago you said you were doing some
special remember and then you were you
got taped to the side of the building
right what what was that that was uh my
last special and the the tour I'm on now
would be my next special oh wow yeah
yeah and this charge is winding down and
yours is just revving up you got the one
man show yeah the one-man show it's
called stick with the dancing
um I wouldn't be doing this if I didn't
think that people were interested in it
because it's a lot of [ __ ] work right
and it's tiring and it's very emotional
for me yeah because you're going back in
time you're picking up you're picking up
the scabs you're like [ __ ] so after
the show sometimes I can't sleep because
you don't want to talk about your past
you want to move on right you know what
I mean and um so it's
it's cool we'll see what happens what
happens to it you know as far as where
it goes and when it comes out good is
there anything else that that your your
Instagram yeah I have my Instagram but I
also want you to mention my band Pauly
Shore and the krusties Holly showing the
crusties there it is so I have a band
with me I'm telling us this
someone was just telling me that Paulie
Shore is doing music he's got his band
Yes it's me and these senior citizens
it's basically me and these old guys but
they're really one of those old guys was
on your podcast with yeah bill yeah yeah
yeah Bill de jillio I met him at
Starbucks I was at Starbucks in silver
like probably about five years ago and I
see this guy's like four foot tall he
looks like Larry David he's [ __ ]
hilarious so I grab him and I put them
on my podcast and come to find out he
plays guitar in a church so he's like he
teaches guitar so he's like a great
guitar player so I'm like [ __ ] I started
a band with him and and he's school so
we're doing an album uh this week we're
going to do a poly show in the crisis
and we record songs in my garage and
it's and it's fun and did he move out to
Vegas as well no he lives in he lives in
La I fly him out on Southwest there you
go yeah and then um I don't know I was
the voice of Pinocchio that came out
recently wow what did that come out that
was on with Lion's gate Jesus yeah and I
have a new uh movie with them called
um a big trip which is uh another
voiceover I do a lot of voice over stuff
with them there you go yeah so um that's
fantastic yeah everything's cooler and
the krusties Polly's short and the
crusties that consume this so if you go
to just my YouTube page or you follow my
Instagram you can see clips and then
also I definitely want to promote the
the thing that it's actually releasing
this week is my new podcast called
jamming the van podcast hosted by Pauly
Shore so I just I just interviewed
musician so I got the girl from uh panic
at the disc goes on the guy from Eagles
of Death Metal how about Vince Neil he
lives in Vegas doesn't he yeah but
jamming the van is in la oh jamming the
vans in L.A yeah
all the time I go back and forth I stay
in Vegas and when people get sick of me
I go to La yeah and then when people get
sick to me in La I go back to Vegas you
know how people get sick here sometimes
like you guys are getting sick of me
ah nah dude you're the best dude
um okay well have we covered the the
bases I had piss surgery pest surgery
yeah we'll talk about that the next time
all right yeah you know is that a
bladder situation yeah it was a bladder
situation all right that's called resume
you had to give yourself your own
catheter I did yeah you did it it's
actually not that gnarly it's not that
gnarly at all it's crazy yeah my uh my
naked tennis champion buddy was uh it
was showing me he did resume he didn't
do resume but uh he was showing me
like how it the the catheter comes in a
pack that's pre-lubricated so like it's
just slimy and it just goes right in and
you better you put it all the way in
until uh well basically what happened
was is I would go to sleep at night but
then I would go pee and then I'll not
all the pee would come out of my bladder
that happens to me sometimes no no it's
kind of rare yeah so it just uh um you
know it's I would pee sometimes four or
five times a night
it got really bad so I went to my gay
urologist Henry Kim in uh in uh at
Cedars he's like let me see your dick
I'm like yo bro that's not cool yeah you
know and then he's like you got two
there's two types of surgery you can get
the resume or the terp the resume is
less invasive so I woke up correct yeah
I woke up and then I had a catheter in
my penis and then I had a piss bag here
and then and then you pee in the bag for
about a week and then they take it out
and then you wait three weeks for it to
work and then you know they steamed your
prostate and uh and and that's it and
now I'm okay and how many times you get
up to pee in the night now
um like once maybe twice but there's
only one problem I'm impotent now
I know that's not true so
probably sure enough you wouldn't you
wouldn't be able to Nazi [ __ ] I was
gonna do a bit about it
he's supposed to respond like really
yeah
you wouldn't be in a good mood of your
room
yeah well hey man it's been a pleasure
dude I'm really glad we got to do this
yeah yeah for sure and congratulations
on all your stuff and you know yeah and
uh you know I hear about you all the
time running around doing your thing
yeah I appreciate that a lot you know
like uh in comedy we basically Chase
each other around we all hear the
stories of uh everybody else and
um you know Scott and I are really proud
that that we've developed a good
reputation for what we do yeah and as
far as the comedy story you know I Am
The Comedy Store The Comedy Store is me
it's my mom it's my family's place and
and my brothers are doing a great job
and uh you know it's as long as the
stages stay open and there's the you
know the development thing and it'll I
think The Comedy Store will be there
longer than all of us I I believe that
you know what I mean I think when we all
die it's still going to be there going
and I think test it until my mom and my
family that it is it's doing well and
supporting Comics yeah like uh it's the
most iconic comedy club in the world and
yeah yeah you should be really proud of
that yep all right brother all right hey
man great to see you later dudes later
down and [ __ ] Carrot Top
there you have it Paulie Shore ladies
and gentlemen was that not the perfect
mix of silly and goofy and funny and as
well as serious and entertaining and
revealing I was impressed I was
impressed by Pauly Shore and uh you know
I I just think it's great I think it's
great that uh all of these comedians
have been coming on the podcast and
having such a great experience with
yours truly Stevo yeah dude and I can't
say it enough that the way that you guys
are having a great experience and I'm
hearing about it on tour you're coming
up to me after my shows and saying man
I'm a street team I love your pocket I'm
hearing it everywhere I go people raving
about how much they love the podcast and
uh it just means the world to me so uh
we're gonna keep doing it man we're
gonna keep doing it it's gonna it's
maybe keep getting better and better so
thanks for sticking around to the end I
love you so much and have a wonderful
day yeah dude